Suppose I give you two different lists of
numbers or maybe two different functions and
I ask you to think of all the ways you might
combine those two lists to get a new list
of numbers or combine the two functions to
get a new function.
Maybe one simple way that comes to mind is
to simply add them together term by term.
Likewise, with the functions, you can add
all the corresponding outputs.
In a similar vein, you could also multiply
the two lists term by term and do the same
thing with the functions.
But there's another kind of combination just
as fundamental as both of those but a lot
less commonly discussed known as a Convolution.
But unlike the previous two cases, it's not
something that's merely inherited from an
operation you can do to numbers.
It's something genuinely new for the context
of list of numbers or combining functions.
They show up all over the place, they are
ubiquitous in image processing.
It's a core construct in the theory of probability,
they're used a lot in solving differential
equations and one context where you've almost
certainly seen it if not by this name is multiplying
to polynomials together.
As someone in the business of visual explanations,
this is an especially great topic.
Because the formulaic definition in isolation
and without context can look kind of intimidating.
But if we take the time to really unpack what
it's saying and before that, actually motivate
why you would want something like this, it's
an incredibly beautiful operation.
And I have to admit I actually learned a little
something while putting together the visuals
for this project.
In the case of convolving two different functions,
I was trying to think of different ways you
might picture what that mean.
And with one of them, I had a little bit of
an aha moment for why it is that normal distributions
play the role that they do in probability.
Why it's such a natural shape for a function
but I'm getting ahead of myself, there's a
lot of setup for that one.
In this video, our primary focus is just going
to be on the discrete case and in particular
building up to a very unexpected but very
clever algorithm for computing these, and
I'll pull out the discussion for the continuous
case into a second part.
It's very tempting to open up with the image
processing examples since they're visually
the most intriguing but there are couple bits
of finickiness that make the image processing
case less representative of convolutions overall.
So instead, let's kick things off with probability.
And in particular, one of the simplest examples
that I'm sure everyone hears thought about
at some point in their life.
Which is rolling a pair of dice and figuring
out the chances of seeing various different
sums.
And you might say not a problem.
Not a problem.
Each of your two dice has six different possible
outcomes, which gives us a total of 36 distinct
possible pairs of outcomes.
And if we just look through them all, we can
count up how many pairs have a given sum.
And arranging all the pairs in a grid like
this, one pretty nice thing is that all of
the pairs that have a constant sum are visible
along one of these different diagonals.
So simply counting how many exist on each
of those diagonals will tell you how likely
you are to see a particular sum.
And I'd say, very good, very good.
But can you think of any other ways that you
might visualize the same question?
Other images that can come to mind, to think
of all the distinct pairs that have a given
sum?
And maybe one of you raises your hand and
says, 'Yeah, I've got one.'
Let's say you picture these two different
sets of possibilities each in a row, but you
flip around that second row.
That way, all of the different pairs which
add up to seven line up vertically like this...
And if we slide that bottom row all the way
to the right, then the unique pair that adds
up to two, the snake eyes, are the only ones
that align.
And if I shlunk that over one unit to the
right, the pairs which align are the two different
pairs that add up to three.
And in general, different off set values of
this lower array, which remember, I had to
flip around first, reveal all the distinct
pairs that have a given sum.
As far as probability questions go, this still
isn't especially interesting because all we're
doing is counting how many outcomes there
are in each of these categories.
But that is with the implicit assumption that
there's an equal chance for each of these
faces to come up.
But what if I told you I have a special set
of dice that's not uniform.
Maybe the blue die has its own set of numbers
describing the probabilities for each face
coming up and the red die has its own unique
distinct set of numbers.
In that case if you wanted to figure out,
say, the probability of seeing a two, you
would multiply the probability that the blue
die is a 1X the probability that the red die
is a one.
And for the chances of seeing a three, you
look at the two distinct pairs where that's
possible and again multiply the corresponding
probabilities and then add those two products
together.
Similarly, the chances of seeing a four involves
multiplying together three different pairs
of possibilities and adding them all together.
And in the spirit of setting up some formulas,
let's name these top probabilities "A1, A2,
A3" and so on and name the bottom ones "B1,
B2, B3" and so on.
And in general, this process where we are
taking two different arrays of numbers, flipping
the second one around and then lining them
up at various different off set values, taking
a bunch of pairwise products and adding them
up, that's one of the fundamental ways to
think about what a convolution is.
So, just to spell it out a little more exactly-
through this process, we just generated probabilities
for seeing two, three, four, on and on up
to 12.
And we got them by mixing together one list
of values, A and another list of values, B.
In the lingo, we'd say the convolution of
those two sequences gives us this new sequence;
the new sequence of 11 values, each of which
looks like some sum of pairwise products.
If you prefer, another way you could think
about the same operation is to first create
a table of all the pairwise product and then
add up along all these diagonals.
Again, that's a way of mixing together these
two sequences of numbers to get us a new sequence
of eleven numbers.
It's the same operation as the sliding windows
thought, just another perspective.
Putting a little notation to it, here's how
you might see it written down: The convolution
of A and B, denoted with this little asterisk,
is a new list.
And the Nth element of that list looks like
a sum and that sum goes over all different
pairs of indices, I and J, so that the sum
of those indices is equal to N.
It's kind of a mouthful but for example, if
N was six, the pairs we're going over are
one and five, two and four, three and three,
four and two, five and one.
All the different pairs that add up to six.
But honestly, however you write it down, the
notation is secondary in importance to the
visual you might hold in your head for the
process.
Here, maybe it helps to do a super simple
example where I might ask you, what's the
convolution of the list one, two, three with
the list four, five, six?
You might picture taking both of these lists,
flipping around that second one and then starting
with its slid all the way over to the left.
Then the pair of values which align are one
and four, multiply them together and that
gives us our first term of our output.
Slide that bottom array one unit to the right,
the pairs which align are 1, 5, 2 and 4.
Multiply those pairs, add them together and
that gives us 13.
The next entry in our output.
Slide things over once more and we'll take
1X6+2X5+3X4 which happens to be 28.
One more slide and we get 2X6+3X5 and that
gives us 27 and finally the last term looks
like 3X6.
If you'd like, you can pull up whatever your
favorite programming languages and your favorite
library that includes various numerical operations
and you can confirm I'm not lying to you.
If you take the convolution of 1, 2, 3 against
4, 5, 6, this is indeed the result that you'll
get.
We've seen one case where this is a natural
and desirable operation adding up to probability
distributions.
And another common example would be a moving
average.
Imagine you have some long list of numbers
and you take another smaller list of numbers
that all add up to one.
In this case, I just have a little list of
five values and they're all equal to one fifth.
Then if we do this sliding window convolution
process and kind of close our eyes and sweep
under the rug what happens at the very beginning
of it.
Once our smaller list of values entirely overlaps
with the bigger one, think about what each
term in this convolution really means.
At each iteration, what you're doing is multiplying
each of the values from your data by one fifth
and adding them all together.
Which is to say you're taking an average of
your data inside this little window.
Overall, the process gives you a smooth out
version of the original data.
And you could modify this starting with a
different little list of numbers and as long
as that little list all adds up to one, you
can still interpret it as a moving average.
In the example shown here, that moving average
would be giving more weight towards the central
value.
This also results in a smooth out version
of the data.
If you do kind of a two dimensional analog
of this, it gives you a fun algorithm for
blurring a given image.
And I should say the animations I'm about
to show are modified from something I originally
made for part of a set of lectures I did with
the Julia Lab at MIT for a certain open courseware
class that included an image processing unit.
There we did a little bit more to dive into
the code behind all of this.
So if you're curious, I'll leave you some
links.
But focusing back on this blurring example.
What's going on is I've got this little 3X3
grid of values that marching along our original
image.
And if we zoom in, each one of those values
is one ninth.
And what I'm doing at each iteration is multiplying
each of those values by the corresponding
pixel that it sits on top of.
And of course in computer science, we think
of colors as little vectors of three values
representing the red, green and blue components.
When I multiply all these little values by
one ninth and I add them together, it gives
us an average along each color channel and
the corresponding pixel for the image on the
right is defined to be that sum.
The overall effect as we do this for every
single pixel on the image, is that each one
kind of bleeds into all of its neighbours
which gives us a blurrier version than the
original.
In the lingo, we'd say that the image on the
right is a convolution of our original image
with the little grid of values.
Or more technically, maybe I should say that
it's the convolution with a 180 degree rotated
version of that little grid of values.
Not that it matters when the grid is symmetric
but it's just worth keeping in mind that the
definition of a convolution, as inherited
from the pure math context, should always
invite you to think about flipping around
that second array.
If we modify this slightly, we can get a much
more elegant blurring effect by choosing a
different grid of values.
In this case, I have a little 5X5 grid but
the distinction is not so much its size.
If we zoom in, we notice that the value in
the middle is a lot bigger than the value
towards the edges.
And where this is coming from, is they're
all sampled from a bell curve known as a Gaussian
distribution.
That way, when we multiply all of these values
by the corresponding pixel that they're on
top of, we're giving a lot more weight to
that central pixel and much less towards the
ones out at the edge.
And just as before, the corresponding pixel
on the right is defined to be this sum.
As we do this process for every single pixel,
it gives a blurring effect which much more
authentically simulates the notion of putting
your lens out of focus or something like that.
But blurring is far from the only thing that
you can do with this idea.
For instance, take a look at this little grid
of values which involves some positive numbers
on the left and some negative numbers on the
right, which I'll color with blue and red
respectively.
Take a moment to see if you can predict and
understand what effect this will have on the
final image.
So in this case, I'll just be thinking of
the image as grey scale instead of coloured.
So each of the pixels is just represented
by one number instead of three.
And one thing worth noticing is that as we
do this convolution, it's possible to get
negative values.
For example, at this point here if we zoom
in, the left half of our little grid sits
entirely on top of black pixels which would
have a value of zero.
But the right half of negative values all
sit on top of white pixels which would have
a value of one.
So when we multiply corresponding terms and
add them together, the result will be very
negative.
And the way I'm displaying this with the image
on the right, is to color negative values
red and positive values blue.
Another thing to notice is that when you are
on a patch that's all the same color, everything
goes to zero since the sum of the values in
our little grid is zero.
This is very different from the previous two
examples where the sum of our little grid
was one, which let us interpret it as a moving
average and hence a blur.
All in all, this little process basically
detects wherever there is variation in the
pixel value as you move from left to right.
And so it gives you a kind of way to pick
up on all the vertical edges from your image.
And similarly, if we rotated that grid around
so that it varies as you move from the top
to the bottom, this will be picking up on
all the horizontal edges.
Which in the case of our little pie creature
image, does result in some pretty demonic
eyes.
This smaller grid, by the way, is often called
a kernel.
And the beauty here is how just by choosing
a different kernel, you can get different
image processing effect.
Not just blurring your edge detection but
also things like sharpening.
For those of you who have heard of a convolutional
neural network, the idea there is to use data
to figure out what the kernels should be in
the first place.
As determined by whatever the neural network
wants to detect.
Another thing I should maybe bring up is the
length of the output.
For something like the moving average example,
you might only want to think about the terms
when both of the windows fully align with
each other.
Or in the image processing example, maybe
you want the final output to have the same
size as the original.
Now, convolutions as a pure math operation,
always produce an array that's bigger than
the two arrays that you started with.
At least assuming one of them doesn't have
a length of one.
Just know that in certain computer science
context, you often want to deliberately truncate
that output.
Another thing worth highlighting is that in
the computer science context, this notion
of flipping around that kernel before you
let it march across the original, often feels
really weird and just uncalled for.
But again, note that that's what's inherited
from the pure math context, where like we
saw with the probabilities, it's an incredibly
natural thing to do.
And actually, I can show you one more pure
math example where even the programmers should
care about this one because it opens the doors
for much faster algorithm to compute all of
these.
To set up what I mean by faster here, let
me go back and pull up some Python again and
I'm going to create two different relatively
big arrays.
Each one will have 100,000 random elements
in it and I'm going to assess the run time
of the convolve function from the Numpy library.
And in this case, it runs it for multiple
different iterations, tries to find an average
and it looks like on this computer, at least,
it averages at 4.87 seconds.
By contrast, if I use a different function
from the SciPy library called FFT convolve,
which is the same just implemented differently,
that only takes 4.3 milliseconds on average.
So, three orders of magnitude improvement.
And again, even though it flies under a different
name, it's giving the same output that the
other convolve function does, it's just doing
something to go about it in a cleverer way.
[Music]
- Remember how with the probability example,
I said another way you could think about the
convolution was to create this table of all
the pairwise products and then add up those
pairwise products along the diagonals.
There's, of course, nothing specific to probability.
Anytime you're convolving two different lists
of numbers, you can think about it this way.
Create this kind of multiplication table with
all Pairwise products and then each sum along
the diagonal, corresponds to one of your final
outputs.
One context where this view is especially
natural, is when you multiply together two
polynomials.
For example, let me take the little grid we
already have and replace the top terms with
1, 2X and 3X squared and replace the other
terms with 4, 5X and 6X squared.
Now, think about what it means when we're
creating all of these different pairwise products
between the two lists.
What you're doing is essentially expanding
out the full product of the two polynomials
I have written down.
And then when you add up along the diagonal,
that corresponds to collecting all like terms.
Which is pretty neat, expanding a polynomial
and collecting like terms is exactly the same
process as a convolution.
But this allows us to do something that's
pretty cool.
Because think about what we're saying here,
we're saying if you take two different functions
and you multiply them together, which is a
simple point wise operation, that's the same
thing as if you had first extracted the coefficients
from each one of those, assuming they're polynomials,
and then taking a convolution of those two
lists of coefficients.
What makes that so interesting is that convolutions
feel, in principle, a lot more complicated
than simple multiplication.
And I don't just mean conceptually they are
harder to think about, I mean computationally
it requires more steps to perform a convolution
than it does to perform a point wise product
of two different lists.
For example, let's say I gave you two really
big polynomials.
Say each one with 100 different coefficients.
Then if the way you multiply them was to expand
out this product, you know, filling in this
entire 100X100 grid of pairwise products.
That would require you to perform 10,000 different
products.
And then when you're collecting all the like
terms along the diagonals, that's another
set of around 10,000 operations.
More generally in the lingo, we'd say the
algorithm is O of N squared.
Meaning for two lists of size N, the way that
the number of operations scales, is in proportion
to the square of N. On the other hand, if
I think of two polynomials in terms of their
outputs, for example, sampling their values
at some handful of inputs.
Then multiplying them only requires as many
operations as the number of samples.
Since again it's a point wise operation and
with polynomials, you only need finitely mini
samples to be able to recover the coefficients.
For example, two outputs are enough to uniquely
specify a linear polynomial.
Three outputs would be enough to uniquely
specify a quadratic polynomial and in general,
if you know N distinct outputs, that's enough
to uniquely specify a polynomial that has
N different coefficients.
Or if you prefer, we could phrase this in
the language of systems of equations.
Imagine I tell you, I have some polynomial
but I don't tell you what the coefficients
are, those are a mystery to you.
In our example, you might think of this as
the product that we're trying to figure out.
And then suppose I say, I'll just tell you
what the outputs of this polynomial would
be if you inputted various different inputs
like 0, 1, 2, 3 on and on.
And I give you enough so that you have as
many equations as you have unknowns.
It even happens to be a linear system of equations
so that's nice.
And in principle, at least, this should be
enough to recover the coefficients.
So the rough algorithm outline then would
be whenever you want to convolve two lists
of numbers, you treat them like they're coefficients
of two polynomials.
You sample those polynomials at enough outputs,
multiply those samples point wise, and then
solve the system to recover the coefficients
as a sneaky backdoor way to find the convolution.
And as I've stated it so far, at least, some
of you could rightfully complain, Grant, that
is an idiotic plan.
Because for one thing, just calculating all
these samples for one of the polynomials we
know, already takes on the order of N squared
operations.
Not to mention, solving that system is certainly
going to be computationally as difficult as
just doing the convolution in the first place.
So like, sure, we have this connection between
multiplication and convolutions but all of
the complexity happens in translating from
one viewpoint to the other.
But there is a trick.
And those of you who know about fourier transforms
and the FFT algorithm, might see where this
is going.
If you're unfamiliar with these topics, what
I'm about to say might seem completely out
of the blue.
Just know that there are certain paths you
could have walked in math that make this more
of an expected step.
Basically the idea is that we have a freedom
of choice here.
If instead of evaluating as some arbitrary
set of inputs like 0, 1, 2, 3 on and on, you
choose to evaluate on a very specially selected
set of complex numbers.
Specifically the ones that sit evenly spaced
on the unit circle, what are known as the
roots of unity.
This gives us a friendlier system.
The basic idea is that by finding a number
where taking its powers falls into this cycling
pattern, it means that the system we generate
is going to have a lot of redundancy in the
different terms that you're calculating.
And by being clever about how you leverage
that redundancy, you can save yourself a lot
of work.
This set of outputs that I've written has
a special name.
It's called the discrete fourier transform
of the coefficients.
And if you want to learn more, I actually
did another lecture for that same Julia MIT
class, all about discrete fourier transforms.
And there's also a really excellent video
on the channel reducible, talking about the
fast fourier transform, which is an algorithm
for computing these more quickly.
Also Veritasium recently did a really good
video on FFTs so you've got lots of options.
And that fast algorithm really is the point
for us.
Again, because of all this redundancy, there
exist a method to go from the coefficients
to all of these outputs.
Where instead of doing on the order of N squared
operations, you do on the order of N times
the log of N operations which is much much
better as you scale to big lists.
And importantly, this FFT algorithm goes both
ways.
It also lets you go from the outputs to the
coefficients.
Though bringing it all together, let's look
back at our algorithm outline.
Now, we can say, whenever you're given two
long lists of numbers and you want to take
their convolution, first, compute the fast
fourier transform of each one of them.
Which in the back of your mind, you can just
think of as treating them like they're the
coefficients of a polynomial and evaluating
it at a very specially selected set of points.
Then, multiply together the two results that
you just got, point wise, which is nice and
fast.
And then do an inverse fast fourier transform
and what that gives you is the sneaky back
door way to compute the convolution that we
were looking for.
But this time, it only involves O of N log
N operations.
That's really cool to me.
This very specific context where convolutions
show up, multiplying two polynomials, opens
the doors for an algorithm that's relevant
everywhere else where convolutions might come
up.
If you want to add probability distributions
to some large image processing, whatever it
might be.
And I just think that's such a good example
of why you should be excited when you see
some operation or concept in math show up
in a lot of seemingly unrelated areas.
If you want a little homework, here's something
that's fun to think about.
Explain why when you multi two different numbers,
just ordinary multiplication the way we all
learn in elementary school, what you're doing
is basically a convolution between the digits
of those numbers.
There's some added steps with carries and
the like but the core step is a convolution.
In light of the existence of a fast algorithm,
what that means is if you have two very large
integers, then there exist a way to find their
product that's faster than the method we learn
in elementary school.
That instead of requiring O of N squared operations,
only requires O of N log N. Which doesn't
even feel like it should be possible.
The catch is that before this is actually
useful in practice, your numbers would have
to be absolutely monstrous.
But still it's cool that such an algorithm
exists.
And next up, will turn our attention to the
continuous case with the special focus on
probability distributions.